في قاعه الارمن الملاسقه لكنيسه المهدي
ببيت لحم وسط ضفه الغربيه اعاد ابن
المدينه الفنان الراحل جورج سمور توثيق
المكاني من خلال معرض اقامته عائلته
بالتنسيق مع بلديه بيت لحم 65 لوحه تحكي
تاريخ العديده من الاماكن المقدسه في
القدس وبيت لحم ويافا وغيرها من المدن كان
الفنان الراحل سمور يحلم في ان يراها
معلقه على واجهه معرض يحمل اسمائه قبل ان
يخطفه الموت اثر اصابته بفيروس كورونا
المفروض يكون في بيت لحم عاصمه الثقافه
العربيه
اوه كان في اشهر بس للمعرض همم حضر كلمه
ووقعها حكايه اطبعها وطلعها للبلديه دخله
الكرونه
وتوفى والده وتطرنا انه نسوي المعرض لانه
هذا حلم كان هو معني فيه هذا المعرض الذي
حمله اسم الاراضي المقدسه عبر التاريخ عاد
فيه الفنان الراحل الحياه اللي رسومات كان
خطها مستشركون بالفحم قبل مئات السنين
عندما زاروا هذه البلاد بعد ان جلبها من
ديارها في ايطاليا وبريطانيا وتركيا
فكره هذا المعرض عام 1990 همم بدا يوثق
تاريخ بيت لحم همم سافر عده دول وحصل على
وثائق تاريخيه لمدينه بيت لحم ومنها
رسومات بقلم الرصاص والفحم رسمها فنانين
من السابق في زياراتهم لمدينه بيت لحم
وهذه الوثائق محفوظه في عده مكتبات دوليه
هذه اللوحات التي امضى الفنان جورج سمور
20 عاما وهو يخطها بريشته الزيتيه بما
فيها تلك اللوحات الخاصه به حمله زوار
المعرض في رحله عبر التاريخ لبلاد مرت بها
حضاره مختلفه كل صوره بتعبر عن تاريخ معين
عن حضاره معينه عن وقت معين واضح انه
الشباب اليوم جيل اليوم يتعلموا ويشوفوا
اللي يحافظوا على فن الرسم
القديم اللي كان موجود
المعرض الذي يستمر خلال اليومين المقبلين
ياتي ضمن فعاليات متعدده تقيمها بلديه بيت
لحم احتفالا بتاسيس البلديه قبل 100 و50
عاما